there is no peace in Hong Kong
angry and afraid the youth have
mobilized
in the city streets thousands clash with
police umbrellas and bottles vs. shields
and patterns
through clouds of tear gas they push
forward you can see the protesters have
just broken through the barrier that
surrounding the Legislative Building
there and some are trying to come down
from the other end
[Music]
their aim to breach parliament to stop
an extradition bill they believe puts
their freedoms at risk from China we do
have a say here demonstrators came
prepared for trouble but many felt it
was an unfair fight
[Applause]
she fired indiscriminately at us at our
first aid station we had the patients
with us they were bleeding they were you
know they had tear gas and the eyes
we just want we just want the world to
know that we're angry that the police
use an unruly brutality against us but
the violence is escalating some gathered
bricks and sharpened sticks
the police responded with rubber bullets
and while protesters have managed to
delay a debate on the bill Hong Kong's
leader isn't backing down
Wow am I gone what do you know who
Michael
Oh a little sometimes I don't autumn saw
your home oh yeah that's how your
signature what do you do is you follow
my work they know talk to Thomas you've
got his own and so it seems this city
will fight on tearing itself apart with
no sign of a resolution Siobhan Robbins
Sky News Hong Kong